in this video we'll be talking about
shine dalgarno and kak sequence this
video is included in the series called
quick concept where we discuss Concepts
within 3 to 4 minutes shine dalaro
sequence is present in the procaryotic
MRNA in the five Prime utr here is the
shine dalaro sequence and this
particular sequence is important for
ribosomal subunit to bind towards the
MRNA here is the start codon and here is
the shine dalgarno sequence you can see
shine dalaro quence is a purine Rich uh
sequence which contains mostly A and
G and the shine dalaro sequence is
complementary to the anti-shine dalaro
sequence in the small ribosomal subunit
actually the 16s rrna portion present in
the small ribosomal subunit is actually
complementary to this shine dalgarno
sequence this facilitates the ribosome
binding to the shine algaro sequence and
this is crucial step in Translation
initiation it ensures the elongation
Factor bound TRNA can locate the start
coton in more proficient way it ensures
the ribosome starts translating the MRNA
from the correct position and it does
not mess up this situation so it really
uh improvise the Precision of this
procedure just like shine dalaro
sequence is present in the procaryotes
ukar has KAC sequence
KAC sequence is bit different and KAC
sequence internally contains the start
code on
Aug and it so basically KAC sequence has
a similar function it helps identifying
the correct start codon for protein
synthesis to
happen now the consensus sequence for uh
KAC sequence has the start codon inside
it and it is also included in the five
Prime utr of the eukariotic MRNA a so
this helps the ribosomal small subunit
to be recruited in the cap and ribosomal
subunit can literally scan the five
Prime utr to locate the first start
codon and thereby ribosomal assembly
happens and translation initiation
begins in the
ukar it's important to note that various
KAC sequences might have might affect
the translation efficiency if the KAC
sequence is strong it enhances the
recognition of the correct Aug codon if
it is weak then it might lead to
initiation down initiation of
translation from any Downstream start
codon and it should not start the
translation from a proper orientation
again like s shine dalaro sequence Co
KAC sequence also ensure the Precision
of translation initiation I hope this is
useful see you in next
video
[Music]